so the bigger division you have the more
important it is for you on what type of
a team is going to put around simple as
that and I think one of the challenges
with people when it's about putting the
team around them they want to be
something they're not so everybody wants
to be the shack where the LeBron or the
Kobe instead of realizing what your
strength is I'm going to talk about that
a little bit today I'm gonna talk about
ten different roles strengths and
departments within a company so as
you're looking at this everybody that's
looking at this you may be at a
different position in your life you may
be a salesperson you may be an
entrepreneur that's just getting started
maybe your midsize business that you may
look at this and say this is what we
lack or it may be somebody that's an
executive and an older part of a company
that's saying this is what area I am
very good at and I need to reposition
myself here regardless of where you're
at this is how I want you to look at
this you this video is for you no one
else I want you to look at this video as
you and as I go through this I need you
to ask yourself which one is me give me
your 1 2 3 yourself I'm one there's two
there's three this and if you think
that's you verified with somebody who
knows you very well for them to say I
really think you're more distance this
if you're willing to get some honest
feedback from somebody so let's get
right into it look 10 different roles
within a company first we have the biz
dev and nothing is any specific order
I'm just telling you what's what first
you have the business somebody who is
doing business development for company
what is biz dev here's what biz dev is
in the world of politics if you're
running a country an ambassador that is
a US ambassador that deals with
relations in the Middle East
hypothetically the biz dev person is
doing the dirty work very very important
role but they do the dirty work so you
need to go out there and sit and talk to
the political powers the Senators the
congressmen the president of a country
in the Middle East Iran quit whatever it
is and ask them they're going to say no
we really don't like your president that
Aeons announced this this this this that
or we really don't like how this
partnership or relationships going up we
don't like how you're doing this that's
miss dev and the Ambassador is supposed
to create a synergy of them still
wanting to do business together and
bring in a relationship that possibly
was sour rekindle this
rekindle this is strengthened this is
rebuild this is a lot of RiRi Ria's
business okay next we can go into the
visionary the visionary is what a lot of
people want to become visionaries but
not everybody is a visionary let me
explain to what I mean by what is not
not everybody's a vision if you ask him
basketball everybody wants to be like
Mike modern-day everybody wanted to be a
Kobe or everybody wants to be a LeBron
James but maybe you're a Steve Kerr you
know maybe you're a you know maybe
you're somebody that say you know Steph
Curry maybe you're somebody that's just
a role player maybe you're a six man
maybe you're a big guy that you don't
have good footwork but you're somebody
that the other Center is getting good on
working with you because you're stronger
you push them out you're bullying I mean
you're strengthen him maybe you're
somebody that's good at playing with
little guys and doing their legs and
tape and all this other stuff so what is
the role you're playing a visionary
would generally be called the CEO now
sometimes some companies make the
mistake of just because somebody's title
is CEO doesn't mean they're a visionary
sometimes companies make a mistake in
they hire eight operations person who
becomes a CEO and what this guy who's an
operation internally but is the CEO all
he's trying to do is make all the
systems perfect and they're wondering
how come the company's not exploding
because you're not a CEO your operations
your receipt oh oh not us not a CEO
you're not a face you're not someone
that's going to say we're going to go
and take over this market let me give
you a good example of a CEO I'm gonna
butcher his name Roberto Gouda say it
again goo goo shweta okay this guy is a
fascinating guy to study
he's a Cuban immigrant okay went to Yale
just so you know this he used to make
$500 a month as a chemical engineer then
he comes to America somehow someway
after being an immigrant from Cuba he
becomes the CEO of Coca Cola and he goes
from making $500 a month to getting an
83 million dollar bonus check when he
worked at coca-cola so why is this why
did this happen well for the longest
time for the longest
coca-cola dominated the marketplace for
the longest time now in the early 80s
Pepsi started coming close to the point
where Pepsi got 23% of the market share
and coca-cola only had 22% now Roberto
gets hired in 1981 I believe is when it
gets higher okay and this number I just
gave you 23 percent to 21 22 percent
Pepsi or coke pepsi moved past coke
first time ever first time ever they
passed coke roberto comes in and here's
what he asks look look at the way he
thinks he says well I want to know this
the average human being how much do they
drink a day and they say Roberto this is
how much we're selling right now bottles
of coke per day so no no no I'm asking
you how much do they consume of drinks
per day what are you talking about
listen how much does a person drink
water milk um tea juice ice tea coke I
want to know everything how much does
the person drink they're like oh my god
where's this guy going with this thing
here here's how they drink any comes
like he said that's exactly what we need
to do I want a bigger market share of
how much somebody consumes of drinks
fascinating look what happens down so
what does he come out with here's what
he comes out with most of us only know
about coca-cola Diet Coke cokes or all
these other things ready minute mate is
a coke product okay Fantas a coke
product we got Dasani water is a coke
product Nestea tea nestea tea coke
product Bacardi mixers is a coke product
okay severe flavored milks a root beer
or Dwolla juices Zico coconut waters you
know how many people nowadays like to
drink the coconut waters that's his
power rate is simply orange his high C
is his you know what ends up happening
with coca-cola coca-cola goes from the
type of numbers that were putting up
which in 1981 was 4.3 billion dollars
per year to 152 billion dollars per EUR
there today
selling two billion coca-cola bottles
per day two billion is
they sell per day now why did that
happen why did that happen why did that
happen it happened because coca-cola
went and hired a visionary not because
they got an Operations guy they hired a
visionary and a visionary said we need
to get more of this so are you a CEO
type yourself that could motivate you
but maybe you're not the visionary top
and that's fine
operation what's operation system crn
flow how long does it take from the
person that looks at your website to
buying a product to converting to being
a be back customer what can we make to
get these customers that we have we have
60,000 customers here what can we do to
get these 60,000 customers to help us
get to there's 60,000 customers because
we're so good on the front end but we're
not doing good on this side here
you know what CRM do we need how can we
get the counter to be better up you know
hiring new people we need more staff
here we need a person here we need to
fire this person we need to renegotiate
this here this thing's not working on
this vendor relate that's operations
operations are thinking like that
operations will come and I say I can
make the operations of this better so
critical may be boring to some it's so
critical for any company so that would
be a seat oh oh then we have finance
finances QuickBooks payroll commissions
vendor checks attorneys making sure
attorneys you're negotiating the
contracts with the attorneys the right
way CPA accounting the team assistant
analysts all these things that you're
going to have to do when you're running
finance by the way when you're a rookie
entrepreneur guess what you are every
one of them is what you are okay so then
you have to see up on the finance I
don't have expansion who's expansion
expansion somebody that says you know we
need to go to a brand new marketplace so
expansion thinks about building a team
together for us to go to a new market
this could be a see a chief expansion
officer there's actually a chief
expansion of it sounds like a CEO but
it's a chief expansion officer and their
job is simply hey we're not in East
Coast we want to go to East Coast what
do we need to do Papapa great hey we're
not in South America what do we need to
do that that does for you maybe local
like somebody okay
men visited me when I was in Palm
Springs he drove all the way down to
come and visit me and he runs a Mobile
Detailing company which I'm very
familiar with the Mobile Detailing
company and nowadays it's getting into
the app site there's a lot of
opportunity and that is well similar to
Ober that you just order something and
somebody comes in services your car
right and there is high-end 100 bucks
like right now literally three minutes
before I did the video my BMW i8 just
got serviced somebody comes does it you
don't even see it just it gets done they
pick it up they clean up right okay so
he came to me says hey what do I do
so he's in San Diego and how does he get
into you know maybe a Temecula market
how does he get into Riverside how do
you get into LA the expansion for that
person maybe within that area
somebody can put a strategy on how to do
that marketing marketing is just very
very critical this could be a CMO
marketing could be when a customer
thinks about our company what's the
first word that comes to mind what do
our employees think about our company
what does what do our customers what
does the market what does our
competitors what does our enemy think
about us how do we want to market our
product which funnels are we using is it
more about social medias and more about
Internet should we go on TV what is our
ROI on TV do we really are we really
doing this because we want people to
look at our commercial and come and buy
do they don't really do it for that but
maybe it's effective if we spend this
three and a half million dollars to put
a commercial on Superbowl because our
competitors are going to see that we're
doing better or you know maybe our
existing customers are going to say well
I'm so glad that's my guy that's my guy
that's my guy so it keeps our clients
with us and they keep some proud or no
we don't need to do Super Bowl it's not
our market or market watches this or you
know our demographic is people that are
between 25 to 35 years old our guys
watch TV our guys don't watch soap
operas why are we wasting our time too
so marketing thinks that way okay
complete different ways marketing in a
way also thinks about a person who is a
marketer like if you're a marketer you
know how you think if you're a marketer
marketers think completely different
they go to a restaurant and they
literally look at everything as a
marketer it's a complete different
eyeball that they have next is legal
what's legal in every industry there's
compliance there's laws there's
making sure you are compliant with the
regulators or whatever there with
financial industry is FINRA SEC limp you
know all these other things that you
deal in on that side and real estate is
going to be Department of real estate on
your Department of Insurance it doesn't
matter what you're doing technology is
going to be whole different law that
you're right and anything there is
illegal so you got to make sure you have
a strong legal team sometimes the a type
personalities they don't like to touch
this year because it's we don't need any
help with this why would we worry about
compliance come on man no one cares
about compliance big mistake big mistake
because you need the contracting to be
right this is I spent a lot of money in
that area and I have no problem with it
because it's very very critical to stay
compliant with your business but you may
be watching a saint that's me I love
those types of things
phenomenal it could be information
what's information somebody that's very
good at research somebody that's very
good at studying competition somebody
that's very good at studying trends and
keeping track of updating and st. just
so you know today in a market you know
that the AIG CEO Carl Icahn was called
out by Peter dr. thing this is what
happened with him and they said this and
did you hear about what happened today
in the Silicon Valley marketplace a new
startup was raised 200 million dollars
on their round three and they're going
after this and did you hear about the
FinTech market whatever information guy
is going to give you what is going on
today this is beneficial because this
helps the visionary know how to go to
the next step this helps the market or
know what adjustments to make this helps
the expansion person know what market
places that we need to go and expand and
what not to waste our money and
resources into it this helps finance
know how to adjust hey this is what's
going on over the next six to twelve
months we should be experiencing this or
we should be experiencing that that's
information so CIO and then you have
product development which product
development is what product development
is somebody that says I'm designing a
product typically product development
they're wired in a complete different
way completed from way they will take a
look at this packaging and they'll say
you know I wonder why they put these
four things in the back I don't like it
I think it's makes it flimsy and I think
the packaging should be done a little
bit different see how hard it is this
should be easier because when you do it
this way sometimes it's tougher so it
takes three seconds to package this with
the machine and I know they just look at
a different way than you and I do a
product development person could say we
need to come out with a mortgage product
today that is going to make the
regulator's happy because the regulators
are very concerned about not having an
eight-game product that's a pickup
payment or negative amortization that's
not going to affect this so to make the
regular sigh why don't we come up with
this but to make the cost low why don't
we get rid of this great they work in a
complete different way very important
for product development to be
communication with the rest of the guys
are regularly in the insurance industry
I get calls and I sit on several
different boards that they'll call me
and they'll say what do you think the
insurance financial industry needs to
look at right now next as a product and
we'll have a long conversation about
areas that I believe they need to
completely change and revolutionize
because the insurance industry needs a
lot of disruption right now then you
have sales by the way nothing happens
without sales just so you know this so a
lot of times you know we put so much
attention into everything else so much
attention every position is very
important every position is very
important that you forget to put
constant emphasis here if you look at
companies that go through this they
start going through a downfall you will
see almost every single time if it goes
through this you can 80% at a time you
can go and point it to sales why a great
sales managers no longer there a
chairman of agency who was running the
entire sales department you know is
gotten too casual because his bonuses
are so easy now that he knows he's gonna
hit the bonus within four months and
he's golf and four months added you got
to make some changes to the bonus
structure right so you have a person
that is barely working and you know
nothing about it because everything is
based on no schedule and so you think
he's working but he's not and you need
to make an adjustment and go and partner
with salesforce.com because you need to
make sure that the guys are logging in
every single day what appointment they
ran and who was the person with and put
a number there
you need to run a minimum of this many
appointments they need to spend this
much money you cannot spend more than
this at a bar and that that ought to
track that okay you can see this so you
may be somebody watching this and saying
I'm a salesperson I'm a great sales
trainer I'm a great person that can
build an army and here's a weird thing
you want to know something they
typically make more money than every one
of these guys just so you know this just
I know this these guys typically make
the most money I know this sounds
strange they definitely make more money
than these guys they make generally the
most money because if these guys are not
getting paid what's the motivation
behind the companies done like you think
coca-cola survives without their guys
that are going out there selling
coca-cola to the local nuts it's a done
deal
so sale sales sales is very very
critical so you gotta look at this and
you may say Pat you know what I'm very
good with people I can pretty much go in
a room and strike a conversation with
anybody and get information and talk to
people and they'll tell me anything and
I can I I can I'm a chameleon I can yell
up Willie you may be AB is that person
good for you I'm a very strong
salesperson I can sell I can I'm good
with sales I know how to ask the right
questions and I know that sales flow and
I'm good at teaching this excellent I'm
a visionary I'm this I'm that regardless
of what you are you got to really take
an assessment of yourself and ask what
is my strengths top three what is my
dominant one that I am okay for yourself
and what can I do to become better at
that
by studying others who have done those
areas now the complete opposite side if
you're running the company you got to
ask who is who what am i lacking
generally as a start-up you're going to
wear seven different hats when you get
started you may be the visionary the
best ever sells the operations to
finance the expansion all of these okay
and you may have an attorney that you
put on a retainer that you have hired
but they're hoping you gotta give
$10,000 as a retainer and everything
else for you your chief information
officer is a guy named Google that's
what you do you're googling everything
to find out what it is right so it
doesn't matter what it is eventually
if you want to compete at the higher
market and if you want to get the bigger
share of whatever industry you're part
of you need all these 10 different guys
on your team you need to know which role
you play the best and become the best
you can within that area while knowing
how all the other people are wired as
well so hopefully today you miss a patch
so what was really the outcome of this
video to kind of know what each person
does and to kind of know what's needed
to build a strong team strong foundation
again this is another one of those
episodes that I can go three more hours
with you and just go dive extremely deep
into this and break everything down and
address questions but this is a simple
video we're doing on the YouTube channel
maybe on another setting we'll have an
opportunity to dive into a little bit
deeper into this subject here so anyways
hey by the way for those of you guys
that are looking at these shirts we've
sold hundreds of these around the world
already if you haven't purchased one
this is the entrepreneurs uniform
everybody if you consider yourself an
entrepreneur everybody ought to have
this shirt I'm pretty much wearing this
thing every single day if I'm at the
airport if I'm walking around anywhere
if I could work this every day I have
every single color that we have I think
I got a red one I got a blue one I got a
green one I got a black one and I got a
blue red I think I got all the colors so
if you want to get one of these shirts
I'm an entrepreneur go to value Taemin
store calm if you go to value Taemin
store calm you can order your shirt
there and put it on and when you do get
it take a picture and tag us with us on
Instagram you can tag me on Instagram or
take a picture and snapchat and send it
to me Michelangelo let's put my snapchat
code up here bet David 19 you can follow
it and then if you haven't subscribed to
the channel please do so if you got any
questions about this post your questions
and comments on the bottom take
everybody bye-bye
you